Mr Griffith we're right at the epicenter
yeah
what do you make of what you've seen
I'm sort of confused on the one hand
it's deeply deeply deeply shocking the
idea that these mountains of rubble
still hold people some of them still
alive many of them dead
haven't yet begun to really count the
ultimate number who may have died
so that's one reaction but on the other
hand also the extraordinary response to
this the most disastrous earthquake in
100 years the extraordinary response
both by Tokyo but also internationally
is quite quite phenomenal and it's
heartening
do you think people are still alive I
don't know I really don't know it seems
not but you know what what's there are
these rules of thumb as you know for how
long you keep looking after a disaster
after something like this and they say
72 hours is the so the gold the golden
period don't they and yet as I was just
being told just now they just pulled out
uh somebody alive
just just yeah just just an hour or two
ago and so and heard another so
I think it must be incredibly difficult
to decide when to stop this rescue phase
and move into the next phase which is
also going to have its problems but yes
what a response over 100 countries have
sent people here amazing
and I can just hear the machineries gone
quiet which suggests that they're
looking for so much yeah something
something how would you describe the
scene to my viewers at home
it's a scene of
extraordinarily contorted what looks
like waste but which is in fact
a building
that housed families
children pets belongings and is now just
a tangle of
a terrible Rubble
which conceals those who we fear to find
and who makes getting to those dangerous
for these heroic
people who are doing this 24 7.
it's something that nobody should have
to see
24 000 plus is the death toll at the
moment from what you're saying that's
going to go up significantly higher yes
there are many sort of rumors aren't
there about where it may end up
um and of course Syria has its count to
um and I think it's really difficult to
to estimate uh obviously very precisely
because we you need to get under the
rubble
um but I I'm sure it'll double or more
and that's that's terrifying those are
numbers which
you know we people like you and me we
deal a lot with conflict around the
world we deal with the Syrian conflict
these last decade but to lose 20 30 40
000 people
in a night we don't see that even in
those conflicts so this is uh nature
striking back in a really harsh way
the The Awful Truth about Syria from a
humanitarian perspective is that the
needs the humanitarian needs of the
people of Syria grow each year
and each year despite generous funding
we fail to meet those needs and each
year as a result
the people who live in absolute poverty
in Syria grow now 90 of the population
the economy in in Ruins
I'll be going to Syria the next day or
two and be seeing how
much more difficult it is for them to
cope with this
tragedy than it is here because of those
desperate lost years 10 11 years
for what
um and we know for what it's for freedom
uh and it's
you know it's been excluded and it's and
it's the suffering of Syrian families
all of whom have some relative
who's been detained many of whom have
disappeared Syria it was always our most
important crisis wasn't it until we got
others racing ahead like Afghanistan or
Ukraine
talk to me about the age for both here
and Syria
we're going to do separate appeals for a
humanitarian aid for Syria and turkey in
the next couple of days possibly
tomorrow
for a three-month period in each and
this will be for the priority needs
which will be of course the ones you
would well know Medical
uh Ted Ross the director General who has
been in Syria talking I think rightly
about the fear of a of a second
emergency which would be a health
emergency we worry a lot about cholera
in Syria because we have cholera in the
Northwest already
so those appeals will fund we hope a
good part of the international agency's
response in both these places in both
turkey and in Syria and I want to go
there and I want to go to Damascus to
meet the government to emphasize that
this is an opportunity for the
government also to show how deeply it
cares about its people and how as they
have yesterday opened up access to the
Northwest for humanitarian Aid that's a
good step
we we need to do more we need for
example to get the crossings uh Crossing
points from here into the Northwest we
need to add to them two more well I am I
am hopeful that we're putting it to the
security Council the next day or so and
we need it it's life and death we have a
very clear humanitarian case written